this video is brought to you by a news
voice the news is broken
almost all US media is owned by just a
handful of big corporations fake news is
obviously a huge problem as well and
finding something unbiased can be hard
news voice is revolutionising the news
landscape it's an app that gives you a
personalized news feed by aggregating
major news sites as well as
international and independent media
giving some much-needed balance each new
story shows multiple sources which are
all tagged with their bias in
perspective the news affects almost
everything in our lives what we hear and
read shapes which persons we trust what
we eat what we buy and how we vote even
how we think news voice is created by
its readers as you can upvote stories
that you find interesting so more people
will see them it's essentially a
democratized platform for news plus it
saves you time you get all the news and
all the sources in one app so that you
could be better informed oh and it's
totally for it anyway
get started with news voice today for
free through the link below it's
available on both Google Play and the
App Store and let's get into the video
[Applause]
[Music]
masks something as simple as masks have
managed to put the governments of half
the world up against the ropes
to the extent that some countries con
treatable common sense the most basic
medical recommendations and to the
experience of the most prepared
countries have come up with all kinds of
reasons their citizens should not use
masks in the face of a virus that is
essentially transmitted by droplets
traveling through airwaves noise
necesario que la población utility
masquerade mask areas seek a possessory
interest sente en los pacientes Ponce
intimate raffia yo la satorious an
interest in the Koran pero not in any
English and Tok la posición or Army's
most a pedo coupon for SI tiene una tena
muscaria seunga's ninguna importante de
pasión no and what was the reason for
all of this well basically because the
supply of masks was scarce in this way
something as simple and easy to
manufacture as a mask suddenly became
such a precious asset due to the corona
virus pandemic and as a result very
scarce lacking beds masks and doctors
Europe's Health Services struggle to
cope with the coronavirus shortage of
personal protective equipment
endangering health workers worldwide
industry warns over face masks shortage
for public you see the problem was
experienced to varying degrees around
the world but it was all the same
problem the corona virus pandemic has
triggered global demand for masks for
both health workers and the general
population masks are an essential tool
for containing SARS coronavirus to
however supply and production chains
have not been able to adapt quickly and
produce enough masks to meet the global
demand
I think you will know the rest of the
story difficulties getting masks
especially if we're talking about the
most effective models exorbitant prices
fakes absolutely everywhere and
single-use masks that have nevertheless
been used again and again and again the
exact same thing happened with many
other pieces of medical equipment and
instruments
as incredible as it may sing its in
precisely this environment that some
countries have seen an opportunity to
seize on this shortage and as a matter
of diplomacy and to extend their
political tentacles masks have become
the icon of the latest weapon of
so-called soft power do you want to know
more about all of this which country do
you think is leading this furious
campaign well take a look at this
[Music]
here you go thank me later it is what it
is here you go remember to thank me this
seems to be the slogan of some of the
diplomatic campaigns that have been
launched in the wake of the coronavirus
campaigns which on face value seemed to
consist of offering free health
materials but which in the background
have little to do with solidarity and
much more with political and propaganda
interests and I don't think anyone's
going to be surprised when we say that
China has become the king of this
already well-known masked diplomacy
Chinese officials in their propaganda
machinery are in high gear worldwide
trying to paint the Chinese government
as the solution to the problem rather
than one of the sources of it Sophie
Richardson China director at Human
Rights Watch but but why does Richardson
refer to China as one of the origins of
the problem why do you say the Chinese
government is using its propaganda
machine to make itself be seen as the
solution to the problem
well the first question can be answered
by watching this video that will link
for you above in which we outline why
China has a good deal of responsibility
for the magnitude of what has happened
[Music]
and the second question is the one that
we will answer in this video take a look
at these images
such fanfare to send humanitarian aid to
countries that are having a hard time
does not seem a priority something so
common does it after all when countries
send aid to others who have suffered
events such as an earthquake hurricane
or similar disasters we never see so
many officials in such images
and that leads us to ask ourselves is
this really about humanitarian aid or is
it about something else
well friends experts and political
analysts from all over the world agree
on one thing China never gives something
for nothing
China asserts claim to global leadership
masks by mask Beijing is providing
equipment to hard-hit nations such as
Italy drawing a contrast with the US and
making sure everyone knows about China
thought it was coming out on top from
the crisis by sending planes with face
masks and medical equipment
Beijing thought it could reap the
benefits from being the only power with
the capability for this PR hausky French
journalist and former Beijing
correspondent but why has China been
working so hard to donate these kinds of
materials to half the world
well for one fundamental reason the
Chinese government is well aware that it
is gained a reputation as the country
which collapsed due to the pandemic not
to mention being the geographical origin
of the SARS Cove to coronavirus
[Music]
so it's understandable that is doing its
best to repair its reputation and clears
ujung pings government of any
responsibility which is no easy task and
all of this is cause global criticism of
the Chinese government to multiply at a
time when China already has many thorns
in its side the trade war with the
United States deployment of 5g networks
territorial claims on islands in the
Pacific the escalating technological war
the political clash in Hong Kong and the
re-election of a clearly hostile
government in Taiwan and all of this is
now in addition to the Western
governments criticism of the excessive
offshoring of production lines that have
typically been set up in China another
problem and this
this caused Beijing to suddenly get to
work and to look for a new geopolitical
strategy and right here is where a key
question was asked what if we can turn
the situation around and becomes
something like saviors can we not score
some diplomatic and political points out
of such a mess
and therefore strengthen our influence
in the world
well this explains precisely why China
has set out to send medical equipment
around the world all backed up by a
powerful communication campaign for
example China is sent 1140 respirators
to New York and teams of doctors to
Italy Iran the Philippines and Serbia in
the latter case the Serbian president
even came to kiss the Chinese flag upon
receiving medical supplies and displayed
billboards with Xi Jinping's face and
the message
thank you brother ji avid obscure
soledad most Nepos toy yes'm Dennis put
your possible appeasement here Nagato go
check we're more united Tsunade polish
ammo we had in a queen Madonna Pomona
boy - Missy - Artie - an ordinary public
at Cana in Hungary senior government
officials repeatedly devoted themselves
to publicly thanked in China for their
help and downplaying what they have
received from the European Union another
example of Chinese bootlicking is
Cambodia where all foreigners were
barred from entering to prevent
coronaviruses transmission except for
Chinese travelers despite that country
being the source of the pandemic
Serbia Hungary and Cambodia well you
know what these three nations have one
thing in common their ties to China have
grown a lot in the past few years and
they are all part of the famous one belt
one road initiative this is a plan of
investments and alliances powered by
using pink since 2013 which we have
already discussed here on visual politic
many times the point is that these
displays of solidarity ramp up just when
scandals like this appear China knew the
coronavirus could become a pandemic in
mid-january but for six days claimed
publicly that there was no evidence it
could spread among humans and on top of
all this we have to add the doubts that
are emerging recently about the actual
origin of the virus doubts which can
damage and tarnish the image of China
even more I think it's going to take a
lot more than a few masses to fix that
problem don't you but wait a minute
it's not only the Chinese government
that wants to repair the political
damage caused by this pandemic some of
China's leading companies and
entrepreneurs are also using this
strategy for example Alibaba founder
Jack Ma sent health supplies to several
countries including 500,000 coronavirus
tests and 1 million masks to countries
such as the United States and South
Korea which is very good agreed there's
no question about that all these
donations are more than welcome but
let's not fool ourselves after such
displays of solidarity almost always
accompanied by intense marketing
campaigns many interests are hidden
beneath the surface
[Music]
perhaps the best example is found in
Huawei a telecommunications company that
over recent months have been embroiled
in lots of political scandals and
enormous scrutiny across the world over
doubts that the Chinese government can
use its technology and equipment to
carry out large-scale espionage
activities we told you about that in a
recent video that will also link for you
in the description in case you haven't
seen it yet
the fact is that this telecommunications
company has donated diagnostic
technologies to country such as Ecuador
and the Philippines as well as millions
of masks that have been distributed
among several countries in the European
Union and the United States well to the
European Union United States and also to
Canada a country that by the way has
received a lot of shipments of medical
equipment donated by Huawei which
happens to be precisely where Meng Wang
Zhao is located
this woman is huawei's chief financial
officer and she has been released with
electronic surveillance after months
under house arrest currently she's in
the process of being extradited to the
United States
amia coincidence not at all don't even
think that for a second but hold on if
you think that this strategy this mask
diplomacy is being used only by China
you are very very wrong there is another
country that has decided to compete with
China in this masked diplomacy thing
albeit with a very different motivation
can you imagine which one well listen up
[Music]
taijuan a golden opportunity friends if
there's a country that has shown the
world that no matter how close and
interconnected you are with China you
can still keep the corona virus at bay
that country has undoubtedly been Taiwan
with just under twenty four million
people the island country has only had
440 infections yes yes that's right only
440 SARS Cove two cases and only seven
deaths incredible at this point but true
taijuan was probably the first country
to act as soon as it perceived that
something very strange was going on in
mainland China with a virus that was
initially thought to be a second
outbreak of the SARS code that shook
Asia at the beginning of this millennium
for this reason Taiwan was a pioneer in
implementing early measures such as
controlling access roads to the country
especially flights from China it
promoted social distancing measures and
respiratory hygiene guidelines such as
the massive use of masks from the outset
all these prevention methods have given
them a tremendous competitive advantage
in one particular industry that of
health products
specifically Taiwan is one of the
leading countries in the world in terms
of mask manufacturing but this hasn't
always been the case before the pandemic
only one point eight million masks were
made in Taiwan a very high figure but
what if I tell you that they are
currently manufacturing get ready for
this seventeen million masks every day
what if I also tell you that they are
about to expand daily production to 19
million if I want to produce 19 million
face Macs daily by next month look
remember here that we're talking about a
country with less than 24 million people
which only proves if you want to you can
but what's really behind this wild
increase in production that's up to more
than ten times pre-pandemic production
of course the commercial and economic
interest is one of the main reasons but
in Taiwan's case those are probably not
the most important ones any idea where
this is going well exactly Thailand's
government has seen an opportunity to
counterbalance China and use masks to
increase its international influence
something that fits very well with the
new soft power strategy promoted by
president desiring when something which
we've already talked about on visual
politic in another video if you think
about it for a moment it's a brilliant
idea
taiwan has been losing international
relevance and recognition for many years
if not decades whilst communist china
has been gaining significance moreover
Beijing's policies towards Taiwan have
been of constant harassment and choking
both economically and diplomatically and
this has evidently damaged Taiwan's
relations with other countries and the
question is how can you counter-attack a
superpower like China well by giving the
world what it needs most right now
masks medical equipment and consulting
on what to do and how to do it
for example on this channel we saw how
the Czech Republic followed Thailand's
instructions to contain the coronavirus
all a bit political I want to donate
100,000 week to United States I want to
donate 1.3 million masks to 8 EU states
Taiwan to give 7.0 7 million more masks
to allies and others you see in Taipei
they've really gone for it and there's
also another important factor with which
Taiwan holds the cards quality yes of
course we're not going to be fooled
after so many scandals around the world
concerning the quality of Chinese masks
and the forgeries that intermediaries
have brought to governments around the
world the Chinese government's intention
to improve its image has backfired in
some countries and that is not a problem
shared by ty Webb a country famous with
the development and manufacture of
technological components such as chips
and semiconductors the thing is that
president desire in wen has played all
these cards to bring Taiwan a few steps
closer to the center of the
international scene so far the strategy
has achieved things like this u.s.
supports Taiwan joining w-h-o events in
ministerial phone call and not only that
the crisis alongside the United States
already crumbling relationship with
China before the coronavirus in the wake
of the trade war has made the Trump
administration the pro Taiwan
administration of recent decades
on March 26 2020 US President Donald
Trump signed Taiwan's international
allies protection and improvement
initiative Taipei
[Music]
a law by which Washington would actively
collaborate in improving Thailand's
position in the world doesn't seem like
a bad result does it
China and Taiwan are leading this new
mask diplomacy look they're not the only
ones who've tried it other countries
such as Cuba and Russia also tried to
emulate this particular diplomatic
strategy of course with very much poorer
results but their efforts were not
completely irrelevant
in the case of Cuba despite its
government's attempts all it could
really bring to the table were doctors
without equipment and totally unprepared
for the coronavirus and in the case of
Russia well let's just say that they
already have a lot of trouble at home
anyway at this point it's your turn
what's your experience do you think
donations of masks by China or other
countries have influenced the image of
those countries in your environment what
do you think of this particular
political strategy leave your answer in
the comments so I really hope you've
enjoyed this video please hit like if
you did and don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos don't forget to
check out our friends at the reconsider
Media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that were not mine also
this channel is possible because of
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage I'll see
you in the next video and if you want to
learn more about politics and hear even
more of my lovely voice you can join us
at reconsider Media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
[Music]